premiers essais du système antigel par
hélicoptère ce matin sur le plateau des
lampes de montlouis sur loire en volant
à 20 mètres du vignoble l'hélicoptère
brasse l'air chaud en altitude qui vient
se mélanger à la couche d'air froid au
sol reichshoffen ainsi les pieds de
vigne un système antigel choisi après
étude par 35 vignerons de la hausse est
de la commune pour son coût de 200 euros
par hectare l'hélico si aujourd'hui on a
des conditions climatiques y qui montre
pas des risques de gel l'hélico il reste
dans le garage
donc il reste sur l'aérodrome et l'idée
ils ne décollent pas donc ils ne coûtent
vous coûte rien je pense qu'on va avoir
un gain mais il n'est pas uniquement sur
le plan économique il est aussi sur le
plan paysager une méthode la plus
polluante que la centaine de tours
antigel qu'il faudrait pour protéger la
même surface
ce moyen rapide à mettre en oeuvre
réponse surtout à l'urgence de la
situation
en cinq ans les viticulteurs de mont
louis ont connu trois gelées sévères
l'année dernière ils ont perdu en
moyenne 70 % de leur production
pour ma part ma l'an dernier 80 % de
détruits et puis les autres j'allais un
peu moins en étaient de l'ordre de 25 4
5%
donc voilà ça fait quand même des
petites récoltes depuis quelques années
pas donc forcément les récolte réduite
faut que ma valeur
elle a une toute petite production
bouteille et vouloir pas tout moment
c'est dommage les gelées sont
prévisibles météorologiquement plusieurs
jours à l'avancé et peuvent courir
jusqu'au 15 mai prochain
en cas de gel dix hélicoptères seront
déclenchés pour survoler 300 mille
hectares et protéger ainsi 67 % du
vignoble de la hausse est de montlouis
sur loire